Voiceover:Let's say you're studying
some type of a little hill
or rock formation right over here.
And you're able to figure
out the dimensions.
You know that from this
point to this point
along the base, straight
along level ground,
is 60 meters.
You know the steeper side,
steeper I guess surface or edge
of this cliff or whatever you
wanna call it, is 20 meters.
And then the longer side here,
I guess the less steep
side, is 50 meters long.
So you're able to measure that.
But now what you wanna do is use your
knowledge of trigonometry,
given this information,
to figure out how steep is this side.
What is the actual inclination
relative to level ground?
Or another way of thinking about it,
what is this angle theta right over there?
And I encourage you to pause the video
and think about it on your own.
Well it might be ringing a bell.
Well you know three sides of a triangle
and then we want to figure out an angle.
And so the thing that
jumps out in my head,
well maybe the law of
cosines could be useful.
Let me just write out the law of cosines,
before we try to apply it to this
triangle right over here.
So the law of cosines tells us
that C-squared is equal to A-squared,
plus B-squared, minus two A B,
times the cosine of theta.
And just to remind ourselves
what the A, B's, and C's are,
C is the side that's
opposite the angle theta.
So if I were to draw an arbitrary
triangle right over here.
And if this is our angle theta,
then this determines that C is that side,
and then A and B could be either
of these two sides.
So A could be that one
and B could be that one.
Or the other way around.
As you can see, A and B
essentially have the same role in this
formula right over here.
This could be B or this could be A.
So what we wanna do is
somehow relate this angle...
We wanna figure out what theta
is in our little hill
example right over here.
So if this is going to be theta,
what is C going to be?
Well C is going to be this 20 meter side.
And then we could set either
one of these to be A or B.
We could say that this A is 50 meters
and B is 60 meters.
And now we could just
apply the law of cosines.
So the law of cosines tells us
that 20-squared is equal to A-squared,
so that's 50 squared,
plus B-squared, plus 60 squared,
minus two times A B.
So minus two times 50, times 60, times 60,
times the cosine of theta.
This works out well for us
because they've given us everything.
There's really only one unknown.
There's theta here.
So let's see if we can solve for theta.
So 20 squared, that is 400.
50 squared is 2,500.
60 squared is 3,600.
And then 50 times...
Let's see, two times 50 is 100,
times 60, this is all equal to 6,000.
So let's see, if we simplify
this a little bit we're going to get
400 is equal to 2,500 plus 3,600.
Let's see, that'd be 6,100.
That's equal to 6,000...
Let me do this in a new color.
So when I add these two, I get 6,100.
Did I do that right?
Yeah.
So it's 2,000 plus 3,000, plus 5,000.
500 plus 600 is 1,100.
So I get 6,100 minus 6,000,
times the cosine of theta.
And let's see, now we can subtract
6,100 from both sides.
So I'm just gonna subtract
6,100 from both sides
so that I get closer
to isolating the theta.
So let's do that.
So this is going to be negative 5,700.
Is that right?
5,700 plus...
Yes, that is right.
Right, because if this
was the other way around,
if this was 6,100 minus 400
it would be positive 5,700.
Alright.
And then these two of course cancel out.
And this is going to be equal to
negative 6,000 times the cosine of theta.
Now we can divide both
sides by negative 6,000.
And we get...
I'm just gonna swap the sides.
We get cosine of theta is equal to...
Let's see we could divide the numerator
and the denominator by
essentially negative 100.
So these are both going
to become positive.
So cosine of theta is equal to 57 over 60.
And actually that can
be simplified even more.
Three goes into 57, is that 19 times?
Yep, so this is actually...
This could be simplified.
This is equal to 19 over 20.
We actually didn't have to
do that simplification step
because we're about to
use our calculators,
but that makes the math
a little more tractable.
Right, 3 goes into 57, yeah, 19 times.
And so now we can take the
inverse cosine of both sides.
So we could get theta is equal to the
inverse cosine, or the
arc cosine, of 19 over 20.
So let's get our calculator out
and see if we get
something that makes sense.
So we wanna do the inverse
cosine of 19 over 20.
And we deserve a drum roll.
We get 18.19 degrees.
And I already verified that my
calculator is in degree mode.
So it gets 18.19 degrees.
So if we wanted to round,
this is approximately
equal to 18.2 degrees,
if we wanna round to the nearest tenth.
So that essentially gives us a sense
of how steep this slope actually is.